Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And I got a very
special guest today. You know, I love
testimonies, especially powerful
testimonies of people coming out of, you
know, cults and new age and all kinds of
darkness because I can identify with
that. I was once in the darkness and
thanks to God, he pulled me out of that
darkness. And this is my very special
friend, guest DJ Curious. What's up,
man?
>> What is up, Candid Truth? I am excited
to be here.
>> I love those glasses.
>> Right. I got the memo. [music]
>> What you know about that?
[laughter]
>> Go DJ.
>> Uh, it was so good to meet you guys. I
can't believe we just spent like the
best weekend ever at
>> Yeah. So, what's up with that? We were
in Arizona. I'm from I'm from
Chattanooga. DJ's from Cali. What part
of Cali?
>> Yep. SoCal.
>> SoCal. And we were in Arizona at the
International Truth Expo just last
weekend. It was awesome.
>> Yeah,
>> it really was a great time. I was
looking forward to meeting you guys.
I've been a fan of the channel for a
while now. um just because of all the
things that you do to spread truth,
especially the cinema connections to
just the dark forces in this world and
their agendas that play out in innocent
animation or movie plots. And I was
like, dude, this is exactly what got my
attention years ago. So, right,
>> great work.
>> That was awesome. That was a surprise to
me, M. Uh we've been watching Strange
World for a while and love the
conversations you guys have and the
guests and everything and had no clue
that uh you guys were watching. So if
you guys have never checked out Strange
World, what's up with that? What are you
guys doing over there?
>> So you can check out Strange World on
Mark Sergeant's YouTube channel. Um he
is the creator of the flat earth clues
which proposed all of us are living in a
giant Truman Show enclosed structure
thousands of miles wide. you know, maybe
at least as a theory, right? Maybe it
goes on forever. Maybe there's not a
dome. Who knows? But the point is, it's
not where we've been told that it is.
And so, Strange likes to cover all
different uh aspects of our reality
through Oh, yeah. There it is.
>> And you guys go live pretty frequently.
Looks like
>> we are live every Tuesday, 700 p.m.
Pacific. And yeah, come check it out.
There's a lot of great interviews on
there, call-in shows. We break down flat
earth information and um yeah, it's been
Mark has been at it for 10 years on his
channel every week. So, we're over 500
episodes in
>> and you've been his co-host sidekick for
about a year now, right?
>> A year and a half. Yeah.
>> What's up?
>> I was just a fan of the show because,
you know, when you get into all the
craziness and you start going down the
rabbit holes and you finally get to the
one that like, no, no, there's there's
no way the earth is not where we've been
told there's no way. and you finally are
able to look at it, which I can get into
a little further detail. I went looking
for uh to see if that guy from the
documentary was still at it. I'm like, I
wonder if Mark Sergeant's still pushing
that BS, you know, and turns out
>> that stuff.
>> Ladder.
>> I know there are people in our channel
that they still don't agree with that.
Um I don't know. I'd like to do a poll
sometime and see how many I think
>> I think the majority leans towards
biblical cosmology or flat earth. Um,
but there's still some skeptics out
there,
>> which if there are any skeptics out
there, tune in tomorrow because flat
earth Dave Dave Weiss is going to be on
this channel live and he will give three
bitcoins to anyone who can give a single
globe proof. So, go ahead and start
writing down your Globe proofs and jump
in the chat tomorrow because we're going
to be addressing a lot of stuff and I'm
looking forward to that. And that all
happened because again of this
International Truth Expo that we were
just at where we got to hang out. We got
to meet we got to meet a lot of other
people that we we watched their channels
and stuff and it was super cool. It was
like three three or four solid days
hanging out together, man.
>> Oh, that's great. Especially the
connections made like you're saying.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> And it's okay if you haven't looked into
flat earth yet or if you're like it's
too crazy. We can't go there. You know,
take your time. But just eventually you
realize it means
>> it's questioning is the earth really
spinning? It's not just about the shape.
In fact, the shape is kind of like the
least interesting part to me. It's more
about where is the earth? And uh that
leads
>> straight to biblical cosmology if you're
kind of looking for answers. So that's
what happened to me. and the the space
aspect that all of space has been faked.
And if you guys uh don't know that or
haven't seen that yet, there's a video
on our channel. Go under video section.
Usually a lot of our stuff's under live,
but if you go under video section,
there's like a 27 minute video. The
thumbnail shows Buzz Aldrin throwing up
the 666 over his eyeball. That's
undeniable proof. Nail in the coffin.
You cannot deny that they are faking
these missions. But I want to get into
your story, man, because when I met you,
I had no concept of your background. I I
don't even know if you're a Christian or
anything, you know? I I um
Yeah, we had a lot of good talks. I got
to hear some of your testimony. Was so
intrigued that I was like, "Man, I'd
love to have you on to tell your story."
Because, like I said, I love powerful
testimonies and you have one, but I
haven't even heard all of it. So, I'm
getting to enjoy the ride along with our
our viewers here. So, were you raised in
any kind of Christian environment? Your
parents Christian or what?
>> Well, I thought I was right.
>> That's what happens when you grow up uh
Jehovah Witness. You think that you're,
you know, worshiping the true creator of
our earth and of the world and the
universe, etc. And um you know it took a
lot of feelings as a child kind of
realizing how different I really was.
You know they don't partake in holidays
which I kind of understood like oh you
know they would explain to me really
young oh it's because they're based on
pagan beliefs. So I was like okay I kind
of get it. Um you know what does a
Christmas tree have to do with the birth
of Jesus? That kind of thing. So we just
grew up not really participating at
least on one part of my family. I do
come from a mixed um you know family
background where I had grandparents who
weren't Jehovah Witnesses. So they would
still kind of break the rules and be
like, "Here's a Christmas present.
Here's a whatever." So as a kid, I just
grew up kind of knowing both sides. I
was like, I I learned what my mom was
trying to tell me with my stepdad. And
then I had my the rest of the family
going, "Well, you can believe what you
want, but we're also going to do our
thing." And so the point is when you
realize how different you are, you're
going to school as a little kid and when
they tell you to do the pledge of
allegiance, I would just have to stand
there with my arms by my side. And they
explained it to me. It's like, well,
your allegiance should be to God, not
to, you know, to the America. So, it's
like, okay, but you're still standing
out like a sore thumb. Yeah.
>> Where you're being different as a kid
and and not celebrating birthdays and
back to all the holidays. Anything that
had to do with um just a recognized
national holiday or something was just
completely you had to just stand there
or leave the classroom. So it was always
>> wow
>> making me feel
you know kind of awkward obviously left
out
>> but because they package all of that
with well we have the truth and
everybody else out there has the lie.
>> So it's it's a very you know
intoxicating feeling where you know it's
like oh we have a secret is how they try
to push it and package that. And so you
kind of put up with a lot of things for
that. And it wasn't as until I got older
that I started to really question. I'm
like, well, what is it that they believe
versus everybody else because I didn't
even know. But if you are not familiar
with Jehovah Witnesses, the biggest
thing I could say just right off the bat
is they do not believe that Jesus is
God.
>> So that already differentiates itself
from basically every other Christian
denomination. Um, right? So how could
you call yourself Christian even though
they claim to be? They're like, "Well,
Jesus is absolutely not God." And so and
and getting to the flat side, I
realized, whoa, not everyone disagrees
with that. You know, there is still
controversy. Uh you know, who is God
really and what was Jesus's role? Um so
I kind of already grew up in that
mindset.
>> Yeah. Um it is interesting because I
grew up Baptist and then we went into
non-denominational charismatic, but
really so many mainline Christian
denominations all basically believe the
the same thing. It's like Baptist
um actually non-denom non-denominational
charismatic churches are are literally
just like Baptists who wear blue jeans
and speak in tongues. I mean that's like
the difference. They're their
fundamental beliefs are the same, you
know. Um and it wasn't until much later
in my life I I went way out there
because I wasn't finding the answers in
church. I was intrigued with the
paranormal and things like that. So, I
got into the occult world and when I
came out, I was just looking for the
truth and I was like, I'd go to one
church and I'd be like, everything was
great. Like, I love the worship. Hey,
the pastor, he spoke on exactly what I
was thinking about. Where you want to go
next week? Like, I don't know why. I was
just like church hopping. And I was just
like, even though it was amazing, it
wasn't what I was looking for. And I
really started just digging into the
Bible alone after being like a Christian
for like eight years. I was finally
like, there's so many beliefs out there.
I'm just going to find it myself. And I
started finding out that a lot of what
the Bible teaches is contrary to what
the mainstream Christian denomination
teaches. And um I think that's because
the Bible says that Satan's going to
deceive the entire world. You know,
there's going to be a lot of wolves and
sheep's clothing, a lot of false
prophets, a lot of people who on
judgment day are going to say, "Lord,
Lord, didn't we do all these great
things in your name?" And he's going to
say, "You never knew me." Or, "I never
knew you. Uh, depart from me." And he's
actually in that he says, "Depart from
me, you workers of lawlessness." So,
these are people who um claim him with
their lips, but their actions don't show
it. You know, their hearts are far from
him. And that's that's a lot of
Christians today. There's a lot of
Christians that like really don't have
any fruit. And that's what Jesus said.
He said, "You will know them by their
fruits." And it is definitely I'm so
thankful for God's mercy and grace and
patience and longsuffering because like
I said, for eight years, [snorts]
I I called myself a Christian. And I was
not living like one in any kind of way
where somebody would look at me and be
like, "Oh, I bet he's a Christian." Um
>> it just wasn't it wasn't there. But God
was getting my attention in different
ways and that's what I like. So,
>> so you were
what was the last thing you said? You
were finding out that um
[snorts]
>> your belief.
>> Well, I can kind of just a little bit
more background on Jehovah Witnesses. Um
because that's really that is what put
me on this trajectory for truth seeeking
and because they literally call their
religion the truth. But how is that
different than any other religion?
Everybody believes they have the truth.
Um it's just they have separated Jesus
from the father as into two separate
entities.
>> And not everyone knows that right off
the bat. And in fact, if they knock on
your door, they're probably not going to
say it that way right away. They're
going to tell you, "No, we have the
father is Jehovah, and we have so much
reverence for the son. Uh we don't
worship him, but we have pay obedience
to him and the secret is that he is not
God." So they look at themselves almost
like as a traditional Jewish faith that
it's all the emphasis of creation is on
the father. And um but what that did and
I realized over time is it kind of
limits your your love and your
relationship with Jesus who is the
mediator between God. And it wasn't
until I was a teenager
>> that my family actually went through
what's called dysfellowshipping. So my
mom, you know, she she had raised us as
witnesses. By the time I was about 13,
um she had been dysfellowshipped. So
what that is is if you're no longer
abiding by the rules or if you the only
way you can really get dysfellowship or
excuse me get divorced is if you have an
affair. And so she used that as a means
to get out of a marriage with my
stepfather. And but in return it banned
her from the religion which then they
kind of go make you go through herbs.
you really got to work your way back in
being persistent at the meetings and
their meetings are intense. I mean they
have a Saturday, Sunday as well as a
weekday Bible study. So it's you're
constantly having to um participate in
their organization and they've get a lot
of their information comes from what's
called the watchtower which is their
interpretation of the scriptures and
it's their focus and they package it to
their people like hey we're all learning
the same thing across the earth um at
the same time because of how organized
it is. But what you realize is that
>> uh you know they're picking and choosing
scriptures to suit their narrative and
it's a means of control. And so if you
get dysfellowshipped, it's a big deal
because they empower their people to
completely shun you. So if your family
is all Jehovah Witness, like your
grandparents, your cousins, whatever,
your siblings, and you get
dysfellowshipped, they have no problem
just completely turning their back on
you like that. And that makes the person
who's kind of the outcast all of a
sudden go, "Oh, I don't want to lose all
my family." So, you stay in the
organization by following the rules
without with the fear of getting
dysfellowshipped. And then if you are
excommunicated in a sense or
dysfellowshipped, you want to work your
way back in and they just make you feel
horrible about it. Um, so that way you
no one ever leaves again, right? So it
keeps this massive sense of control. And
they would look at it differently, I'm
sure, and and that's fine. They could
try to explain it, but I've been
watching tons of testimony lately on ex-
Jehovah Witnesses, just hearing the ins
and outs of all of the organizational
tactics that they use to keep their
organization solid in a sense of, you
know, they they've got free labor.
people going out into service, they call
it doortodoor um preaching what they
have repackaged the gospel in in their
own narrative and uh trying to get
people to join and then also forcing the
people born into it to stay there so
they don't lose all their friends and
family and their their social network.
So, it's pretty intense. And and what
happened to me is because in my teenage
years, I was had to go live with my
father and uh my parents had my steps
had separated or my mom and my stepdad.
And I'm living with my other with my
what they would consider worldly father
who was not a Jehovah Witness. And um so
then I was kind of free to make up my
mind about religion and what I thought.
And this was back in the late 90s. And
you remember those days? I mean, it was
kind of like a free-for-all. X Files was
a big TV show. conspiracies were huge.
Um, we were in high school and and the
world was just kind of exploding with
pop culture and it was like a heyday for
all sorts of cinema and movies. And I
know you've got your take on all the
gnarly brainwashing that they put and
the agendas in movies especially of that
era.
>> But it became like our language, our
fashion, everything. Like every every
time you were in a social environment,
people would be spouting off lines from
movies and getting a kick out of it. And
it was it's pop pop culture. The culture
became what was popular through the
cinema.
>> Uh yeah, Polyshore and all that stuff,
man. [laughter]
>> Polyshore, man.
>> Going way back now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Uh what's it called? In Cenino Man is
still one of my favorite movies of his.
>> The weasel.
>> Yeah. Don't we the juice. Um,
but you know what was weird about that
time and we know is because the internet
was just kind of growing and starting
out, everybody was basically subjected
to the same channels. You know, if you
had cable, basic cable, was like one
through 50, one through 70, whatever.
And you would watch NTV, VH1, maybe a
different news channel. We were all kind
of watching
>> Yeah. Nickelodeon as a kid. And so that
they were able to create mass hysteria
with pop stars or movie stars and people
of the times because that was the
platforms that these people got. And so
we were so influenced by certain artists
back then and movies because everybody
was watching the same stuff. Whereas
today you can have a little bit more
nuance and and uh you know tailor things
to your own liking. Uh which is why the
celebrity has kind of died down but now
it's influencers. how much how like the
world popularity contest and so but for
us back then we knew you know if you
weren't in on certain things it was like
you weren't cool you you didn't know
what was going on in the world it was
like what are you paying attention to
then you know what I mean
>> that's true I never really thought about
I mean not that I never thought about
any aspect of it but you're really
connecting the dots and making it like
>> they could really shape the culture
because there's only so many things you
could watch um there was no on demand
there was no streaming from your phone
binge watching. It was like once you
flip through the channels, if what you
want to see is not on, you just do
something else. Go outside or watch a
DVD or something,
>> right? Right. Play with those wristbands
that would like wrap around your arm and
so cool.
>> Just kidding. [snorts]
>> But you know what I mean. I mean, like,
what did we do back then? It was a lot
of more outdoor stuff for sure as kids.
Um, but the point is, yeah, if you if if
you're a network and you want to push an
agenda and, you know, you've captured a
certain demographic, you know, the the
teenage demographic, which is what most
movies are geared towards anyway, 16 to
24 year olds and all those shows, it it
started to shape our mind and and
brainwashing. It was literally the
brainwashing u that we realize now that
kids go through without even realizing
how much they pray on that demographic
to push jenjas and make money and and
prop people up that you want they want
us to idolize. And so for me the point
is I go from Jehovah witness which kind
of always looked at the outside as
worldly. anything that was too
mainstream or something that wasn't a
Jehovah Witness, it was always like,
okay, you can you should be very
cautious of whatever is outside of our
organization. And then being freed of
that, it was like, oh, I didn't have to
necessarily worry about, you know,
disappointing the elders or
disappointing the congregation. And um
but I always had this level of
skepticism in mainstream media anyway
because some things they taught made
sense like you know getting back to
holidays. What does Christmas have to do
with Santa Claus? What does Jesus the
birth of Jesus have to do with a tree
and Santa Claus and decorations all
these things. And so it started my
conspiracy mindset from a very young age
of being skeptical of the mainstream
narrative. I never would have thought
that I would someday be talking about
how I think that Jehovah Witnesses are
themselves stuck in some sort of
deception, which is heartbreaking
because out of respect, if anyone of my
family does see this, out of respect for
them that are still participating, uh I
I first of all, they probably never find
this channel and they'll never find this
interview. But if for some reason they
do, I have nothing to hide. Besides
that, they won't let me talk about it
directly with them. And so you can
either continue watching and I'll try to
explain more of why I think that they're
deceived. Um,
>> but also just knowing that I love you
guys and I think that the deception is
bigger than what you're being told.
That's really what I my message would be
to them. Like they believe that the
whole world's deceived as we know it is.
Um, but they're limiting in my opinion
what evil has been able to accomplish
here. And that's when you get into
things like where where is the earth?
What is it really doing? You get into um
other aspects as truth seekers of how
far evil has gone to hide the true
nature of of this realm to hide the
truth and to hide our creator. So
>> yeah. So as a kid did you go out door
knocking and stuff?
>> Sure did. And so most churches they go
to church like every Saturday or Sunday
depending on the denomination and then
they have the doors are open on
Wednesdays for prayer meeting. But
Kingdom Hall they're open like every day
or what? I don't know about every day.
Um they have several meetings a week and
then you are you know expected to go out
into service and participate by knocking
on doors and and they look at it like
hey we're being proactive. We're on fire
for the word and we're going to go and
spread the gospel. Well, their gospel is
twisted once I started to read, you
know, the Bible without their
translation, which is kind of in the
thumbnail. It's called the New World
Translation, which is their way of
interpreting the scriptures. And they
package it as, "Hey, we have restored
God's true name, Jehovah, which was
taken out of the Bible and it's been put
into the the Old Testament." But what
they don't tell their believers is that
they've also superimposed that word,
that name into the New Testament where
it wasn't there. and they pick and
choose when to use the word Jehovah to
represent the father who is to them as
God versus when Jesus deserves the
credit for something and it becomes very
muddy the more you dig in and start to
compare and contrast the original Greek,
Hebrew and Aramaic to the New World
Translation and you can see key things
of when they've changed kind of the u
the deity of Jesus from being accredited
with the Almighty to a separate God. So,
it's very alarming when you realize that
they believe Jesus is a separate God.
And yet,
>> yeah, I've seen that in the in the New
World Translation when you read John
uh John 1 and it says, "In the beginning
was the word and the word was with God
and the word was a God, right?
>> Yep.
>> You're familiar with that?" Yeah. So,
they
>> that should be Yeah.
>> They insert that that uh because that
that scripture is about Jesus in the
beginning was the word and the word is
with God. Let me look that up real
quick. Um, that's Let's see. Bible
Hub, John chapter 1.
Um,
so you see John 1 in the beginning.
Let's see
the witness.
>> Yeah, John one.
>> I don't know why it's not showing. KJ.
Okay.
In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God and the word was God.
So if this is about Jesus because it's
saying in the beginning was the word and
we know that Jesus is the word made
flesh. It says and the word was with God
meaning that Jesus was with God in the
beginning. And then it says and the word
was God. That's that's hard to fight
against you know to say that Jesus isn't
God. But out of all the translations,
you know, Bible Hub has a ton of
translations,
um, theirs is the only one that actually
says that he is a god instead
[clears throat] of was God.
>> Correct.
Yeah. And, you know, they would say,
well, that's because he's divine, but
he's not the almighty. And so, they have
to again tailor other scriptures. For
example, as you continue on saying, you
know, the word became flesh and the
flesh dwelt among us. And um they start
to change that, you know, he's
accredited with creation, so that all
things were made through him, by him,
for him, and nothing that was made was
made without him. Well, they look at
that and they say all other things. And
that's in their translation. You have it
up here.
>> In the beginning was the word, and the
word was with God, and the word was a
god. Interesting. Wow.
So, what else was you saying something
else in here?
>> Well, it came back to the word was a
god. in their prayers, they're praying
through, you know, in the name of Jesus
or through Jesus to God Jehovah the
Father when what what is the first of
the ten commandments? Have no other gods
before me.
>> So, how could you have a lesser God
mixed in with a greater God? It's just I
that's confusing to me. And it's like if
Jesus is on the throne standing next to
the father and you're worshiping the
father and you're supposed to be looking
at Jesus like, "Okay, I'm I'm bowing,
but I'm I'm not bowing to you, but I'm
I'm bowing to that one." and you're like
and God's just going, "Yeah, don't get
it wrong or I'm going to strike you
dead." It's like, "I don't think it's
that complicated."
>> So, um, you know, that's a simple way of
me explaining a lot of different things
that I've picked up on over the years of
studying the New World Translation and
reading the Bible. And you asked how
this even started. Um, but I know we're
jumping all around, so forgive me. I'll
keep it quick, but
>> I'll circle back to how they've changed
their translation. Other things that
I've noticed um when you're up against
Jehovah Witnesses who are very versed in
their scriptures because they are
studying all the time, they know their
New World Translation and they're also
prepared to be going door to door and to
have key talking points and to, you
know, spin the person that they're
encountering, you know, spin them around
in a bunch of circles so that they
>> answer and
>> yeah, handling objections. They know
that they're going to be able to get the
person at the door who's probably hasn't
been studying their Bible as closely as
they have. But if they're studying a
false Bible, then what good are they
doing for themselves?
>> And they're pushing this narrative that
Jesus is a separate God. I mean, that's
just blasphemous if he really is the
true God, right? So,
>> I started to think about that pro end
times prophecy where it says in the last
days there will be false Christ being
preached.
>> And
>> I looked at it like, well, what other
religions are preaching Jesus is not
God? And is that part of this deception
to confuse people? And um it became more
and more clear as I started to read my
Bible. But I would never have been so
intent on trying to understand the Bible
if I wasn't concerned or worried about
was I raised in a freaking cult and I
have these family members who I love
dearly who are trying to push their
belief onto me constantly being like,
"Well, you we want to help you. We want
to save you. You're you're going to be
condemned." And I was like, you know, I
need to read this book for myself and I
need to study your religion and I need
to study why people disagree with it.
And that's where things just started to
completely change my life.
>> Wow.
>> So I see you have Colossians 1:15 up.
>> Yeah. The image of the invisible God.
>> Yeah. He's the image of the invisible
God. Um
>> well they that's the that's a very
important scripture because they would
look at that second half saying the
firstborn of every creature. They would
go case closed. He's born right there.
So he was created.
>> But they don't continue on a few verses
later where it says he's also the
firstborn of the dead.
And they don't give much uh thought into
well was the firstborn always the first
person that was born in a family or was
that a title that was given to someone
who was going to have authority in a
lineage and it started to become clear
to me that there's more than one example
of someone being credited as the
firstborn as a title that then became
the ruler of that you know kingdom etc.
So to me, if John 1:1 is to be taken at
its face where it's like in the
beginning was the word and the word is
with God and the word was God, then
later down the road in these scriptures,
if it starts to make a claim saying he's
the firstborn of the dead, it's not
going to all of a sudden default to this
scripture. You have to take into
consideration what you've already read
and what has been described about Jesus
and then apply the next scripture
towards that. Meaning he is a ruler of
all creation. And so it brings us right
back to the point that I had made
earlier saying you know all things were
made through him and nothing that was
made was made without him. So that would
include himself otherwise but the new
world translation they have to insert
the word other to be very clear that
Jesus is created in their Bible
>> and that's where you see that that was
right here. here is like all things came
into existence through him and apart
from him not even one thing came into
existence
existence.
>> Um you'd probably have to keep
scrolling.
[snorts]
Uh
that is interesting though. Yeah. Like
how would they get around that?
Is it in this section here? Um, I would
have to go back and double check, but
>> I had um this one on screen where it
says, "Who being in the form of God
thought it not robbery to be equal with
God."
>> Yep. So, their version, you should pull
up theirs next because it'll say
something given unto a seizure, which is
already confusing sounding. Basically
saying that it's almost like having a
seizure to be compared to God. So, they
have changed that scripture as well.
>> Wow. Let's see. new world.
I don't know how to navigate their site.
Uh let's see
what was the verse 26.
Who although wait who although he was
existing in God's form did not even
consider the idea of trying to be equal
with God. What? Well, this is different
than even the last time I've looked at
it. So, they're they've changed their
>> But this is the exact opposite.
>> Wow.
>> It says in the King James and every
other translation I've ever read, who
being in the form of God, thought it not
robbery to be equal with God. Meaning,
I'm not I'm not robbing God by saying
I'm equal to God. And yet, it says right
here, who although he was existing in
God's form, did not even consider the
idea of trying to be equal to God.
Wow, dude. They are really changing
everything in the word of God to take
away the divinity of Christ.
I mean, absolutely. And so, it's
interesting because I haven't seen it
worded this way before, but I have
screenshots of other translations of
theirs that say something given unto a
seizure, but never made sense to me.
Anyway, this is a lot more clear to
their people that we are not considering
God uh Jesus to be equal with God by any
means. Um, which is a massive problem if
Jesus is the creator, right? So,
>> yeah, you know, I' I've seen in
scripture because I I've looked into
this, too. I I had a friend at work who
was a Jehovah's Witness and we got to
have some good conversations, but they
always got cut short because we were
actually valet at a hospital. And it was
it stayed busy, man. You know, we live
in a world where everybody's being
poisoned, so hospitals are really uh
staying in business. But we would be in
the middle of talking and I have to go
chase a car or something. And one time I
was like, man, I I've actually like
talked about some of these things on
this DVD. I I'd made a DVD of myself
like doing Bible studies and clearing up
um you know, confusing topics and stuff.
And I tried to give it to him and he
wouldn't even unfold his hands. I was
rubbing the CD on his hand and I was
like laughing. I'm like, "Dude, you
won't even like touch it or what." I was
like, "What's up with that, man?" I was
just like, "We don't have time to talk.
I thought you could watch one of these
videos and we could talk about it
tomorrow." And then I I looked it up and
found out like a Jehovah's Witness can't
even touch other material that's not
their own.
>> Which to me, that's a red flag because
as a truth seeker my entire life, I've
been a truth seeker as long as I can
remember. I mean, second grade, obsessed
with ghosts and aliens, checking out
books in the the library.
Um, I'm not afraid to look at evidence.
I, you know, that's how I actually got
to where I'm at today was because I
wasn't afraid to think outside of what
was spoonfed to me as a child. And
that's why I went into the occult. But I
came out, thank God, because I found out
that that road was a dead-end road. And
I put God to the test and he revealed
himself to me. But I had to keep an open
mind to find what is the truth. There's
so many denominations out here and so I
love listening to debates and I'm like,
"Okay, I I'll listen to a debate on the
Trinity. I'll listen to a debate uh
evolution versus creation." And I know
that the truth will stand. I'm not
afraid to listen to the other side. You
know, some people get a little worried
when they hear that because they're
like, "Oh, you know, Satan's very crafty
and you could be uh don't be persuaded
by every wind of doctrine and all these
things." But I believe that truth will
stand up to the test and that when you
really study line upon line,
um, that you're going to find the truth.
And that's why like I love debates
because they show both sides of the
belief. and I look at all the evidence
and I weigh out the evidence and say,
"Okay, it looks like there's more
evidence over here for this, but now I
need to deal with these like two or
three verses that seem confusing. So,
let me look at it in the Greek. Let me
look at it in the Hebrew. Let me maybe
even read some commentaries, which you
can't trust all those, but I'll I'll
study out why do these few verses seem
to contradict 20. I know that
>> right
>> that the Bible's not gonna say something
20 times and it's not true. So, it's got
to be something confusing about these
other verses. And usually it's context
or the translation because we're reading
English. I mean, the the vocabulary of
Greek and Hebrew, they had words that
meant things that we don't even have
words for, you know? So, you really have
to study that stuff out. And um that's
that's how I've gotten where I'm at. And
it sounds like that's what you did, too.
>> Well, absolutely. I mean, what was
happening to me is I had family members,
you know, such as my mom and a brother
who were just so adamant about their
faith and wanting me to, you know, study
it and become one of them that I started
going to meetings and I started to read
their translation and I had questions.
And I remember with the person I was uh
doing the Bible study with, she had met
me just randomly through work. We worked
at the same place and it was a lovely
lady, same age as my mom. I was in my
20s. And this is at a period of my time
of in my life where I wasn't really
looking to be part of any kind of church
or have that faith, but I really liked
this person. And she became friends and
she knew my backstory of being raised as
a witness up until my teenage years. And
so down the road, I eventually started
studying with her and I just had
questions. We'd meet every week um that
she couldn't answer. And I think over
time it started to make her uh
uncomfortable. But she never showed that
to me. What I realized from watching ex
Jehovah Witness testimonies is that if
you question too many times something,
they start they train their people to
ask you, well, where are these questions
coming from? because it starts to
put up red flags in their mind like are
you must be listening to what they call
apostate which is counter um Jehovah
witness doctrine or information whatever
material like you said where they won't
even touch it and I didn't even realize
in the modern era of being a witness
where now they can use video uh they can
create video kind of movies and
different scenarios to help train their
people um if someone comes to a Jehovah
a witness and starts saying, you know,
well, what about this and what about
that and and I just have been seeing
these things and I don't I I'm
questioning this that they dub over a
satanic voice over that person who's
questioning the the doctrine of Jehovah
Witness, which is and then they're told
in their head, you're supposed to say,
"Flee from me. Get away from me, Satan,
and leave the conversation."
>> So, never questioning their doctrine is
really critical to them
>> keeping the lie together. But with
internet and you know how easy it is to
share testimony. Um it's people are
leaving that faith in droves from my
understanding.
>> Yeah. That is like
>> they can't hide it anymore.
>> Propaganda right right there. Like what
about this verse that says uh I
considered it not robbery to be equal to
God. You know it's like whoa. Get away
from me Satan. You're quoting the Bible.
Flee from me Satan.
You know, I've actually had had some
Christians uh tell me, it's weird
>> when when you really study the truth and
you find the truth and it's contrary to
what the the majority believe, which the
majority have never been right ever in
all of history. The majority have never
been right. And you know in Jesus' day
he was walk he was teaching things that
were so contradictory to what people
believe that so they the disciples turn
the whole world upside down and he was
crucified for it. They were all killed
for it and he's called it the straight
and narrow way. Few will there be that
find it. And I've actually got into
discussions with people where, you know,
whatever the topic might be, what
happens when you die or tongues or
whatever, and I only respond with
scripture, cuz to me, that's how I found
the truth. I'm like, well, here's five
scriptures that say this, you know, and
we're supposed to study line upon line.
And they're like, I've actually had
people tell me,
um, I don't need the scriptures. I am
led by the Holy Spirit. and they will
act like you're doing like you're
they'll actually call you a Pharisee for
responding with scripture alone. Like I
don't I don't get I rateate with people
or anything. I'm just like, "Well, this
scripture says this, this one says
that." And I might like highlight
specific words that I want them to
notice, but I only respond with
scripture because I know that that's the
truth. You know, it doesn't matter my
opinion, my feelings, whatever, don't
matter. But people will get triggered
and they attack you and say that you're
a Pharisee, you're a legalist or
whatever. And I'm like, I mean, I'm just
sharing scripture with you.
>> Yeah, we shouldn't have to be afraid of
the scriptures, right? That's
>> very obvious to me. And again, so I
started talking to my Jehovah Witness
relatives using scriptures from, you
know, King James or just any of these
other translations and and also refer
referring back to Greek and the Hebrew
where it was appropriate um to see where
the Bible had been changed and and
started to document for myself really
why this faith had changed so many
things to demystify or to demote Jesus.
I'm like, look, if Jesus isn't God, then
they shouldn't they wouldn't have had to
change any other scriptures.
>> They would have just been able to just
hand out a Bible and be like, "Here,
we'll show you where he's not God." But
they've had to change so many. So, that
was a huge red flag for me. And it was
still before I was even ready to to seek
Jesus because I I kind of want to go
back just so people get a full story.
Um,
>> you know, I as you get older, you can't
help but notice patterns in the
mainstream. And I know that's one of
your expertise. And
>> back in 2018, 2019, uh, you know, I was
in my early 30s, um, almost mid-30s at
that point, just being like, you know,
what else is there? What is life about?
What's what's our purpose? What is the
truth about this place? And I was really
into space like you had said and into
all those, you know, Hollywood movies
that we grew up with, whether it be, you
know, Alien or Independence Day, Men in
Black, uh the XFile series, anything
that had to do with paranormal and
>> yeah, just alien movies that were just
it was more about what's out there, you
know? Ooh, space. It's it goes on
forever. There must be um other life out
there. And what if we came across maybe
not something that was so terrible? what
if it was really smart and cool kind of
you know that had wisdom that we could
really benefit from which I think
today's people still are hoping for
right um so it always was captivating
like yeah there could be something out
there that's really interesting and it
never really uh replaced God for me in
my mind I I'll give credit to being you
know raised with some part of the Bible
I mean the Bible is powerful that you
could even twist certain things and
you'll still capture an audience right I
mean yeah
>> that's how powerful this book is that
it's in the wrong hands, it still can do
so much damage um because of its wisdom.
Um but I was starting to study space and
going, okay, how does space work? What
do we really know about what's out
there? I was I'd been paying attention
my whole life to alien stuff. So, I kind
of had a good overview that, you know,
that we're missing dark matter and we
don't fully understand how all these
things are being held together in the
universe. But it's pretty clear
according to science that there was a
big miracle event. They couldn't explain
how that miracle event happened such as
the big bang but that's when everything
just got blown into the universe but it
started to cool and things started to
spin and things started to coales and
therefore everything became fine-tuned
and it was a matter of probability um
according to a you know mainstream
science that this universe happened to
pop into existence just balanced enough
for life to thrive. Well, the goldilock
zone.
>> Yeah, Goldilock zone. All of that stuff.
That's like if you're a mainstream
scientist or if you believe in that or
you're an atheist, you're like, "Yeah,
out of probability, this had to have
happened." And it's like, okay, you
know, they still can't explain how all
these if you didn't have space, time,
and matter all coming together at once,
you know, you would have a problem with,
okay, well, if there wasn't time, when
would you do everything? If there wasn't
space, where would you put everything?
If there wasn't matter, how would
everything exist? So all these things
had to be you know very well planned or
just the most insane miracle of all time
which is what they are leaning towards
versus purpose and intention. And I even
though I didn't really have a
huge incentive in my mind at that age to
come to Jesus. I just was like well
maybe God is real and maybe he created
the universe and aliens and we're going
to find out about it. So, I wasn't
exactly dividing the two. I was kind of
blending, which I think a lot of
Christians do, right? If you believe in
space and you're like, "Well, yeah,
what's the big deal? That just proves
how great our God is. The universe goes
on forever."
>> Um, it's like, "Sure." Or you can take
him at his word when he's like, "Look,
I'm done create." When I was day seven,
I'm resting and I'm done creating.
>> So, is the universe really still being
created then? Because it's as simple as
that to me. It's like, probably not. If
God says he's stopped creating for a
while and he's resting and you get into
biblical cosmology and you start to see
how it's in direct opposition to the
mainstream scientific answer for our
existence, which is like, hey, in the
beginning was the big bang versus God
saying in the beginning was the heavens
and the earth. So it's like if the earth
comes before the sun, which it clearly
says in Genesis 1 and the sun is made on
day four, how is the earth circling the
sun if we were relying on its
gravitational pole?
>> Oh. Uh that that's a big, you know,
contradiction versus science going, "No,
the sun is a star and it's so massive
and it's warping and bending spaceime
and it's holding all the planets in its
gravitational pole, bending that fabric
of space we can't even identify and
that's how everything works." Versus God
going, "No, I put it there and I made
you with purpose." So again coming
towards you know starting to look at the
Bible through the lens of well what if
it's right and what if it's true started
to change my life and um so
>> that led me here. you were talking about
um you kind of reached this point where
you started to question things like what
age were you and what what kind of
things did you ever go through like a
falling away a prodal time period where
you just kind of did your own thing
didn't believe in God or what?
Um, I would say I always believed in God
just because of my faith and and having
some really great family members,
grandparents who I loved and just kind
of understanding that there's probably
something that's out there that's knows
the difference between um what the truth
is and what isn't. And I always had that
feeling in my mind because that's how
they attributed especially Jehovah
Witness that you know God our father is
you know the purveyor of truth and
authority. And so I was like, okay,
that's that's actually doesn't bother
me, right? What was hard for me is
giving up space, but that took time. And
so in my teenage years, you know, before
I was really ready to read the Bible, it
was kind of always a book that, oh, I
grew up with it.
>> I'll get around to it one day, but in
the meantime, I got to live my life. And
so I think a lot of kids go through that
where it's like,
>> who knows? Don't care. I want to go do
what I want to do. And so
>> um in my you know right after high
school,
>> well actually in high school 9/11
happened and that was a big wakeup call
for me because as I was watching the
buildings come down live in my senior
year of of high school was like zero
period on the west coast. So early in
the morning, the first thing that my
brain was kind of registering was like
these look like buildings that are
uh coming down high explosives, you
know, demolition. I don't know how much
I can say on here. I don't want to say
something on your channel, but you know,
speech, non-monetized, like whatever,
say it all.
>> Right. So, I mean, my brain is going,
well, this looks like a demolition
building. And that was before the
narrative of, well, no, it was because
of the, you know, jet fuel and the
weight and the the building failed and
all that steel turned to dust. And I was
just thinking to myself, before they
came, that was the next day basically
that they're trying to tell us that. But
in the moment, if you're, you know, an
adult or close enough, you might have
made the comparison in your mind that it
looked like a demolition building. And
if that's the case, then what the heck
really happened, you know? And so
>> I can't believe you were actually
thinking that stuff then. Man, I was
>> I was so far removed from anything
conspiracy theory. You know, the only
thing I knew about a conspiracy theory
was
>> what you see in the movies. Like people
that were in the war, they come out,
they're a little loopy. They think the
government's under every rock and
they're out to get you. That's the way
Hollywood propaganda is used to make
thinking to be smart looks uncool. You
don't want to be smart. You don't want
to be Screech or Urkl and shoved into a
locker. You want to be the dumb guy that
goes to the party and gets the chick.
Um, also the conspiracy theorists were
always these war vets that, you know,
had PTSD and and they were just crazy.
And so at that time I was uh senior year
as well and yeah, partying constantly
and not just Dude, I was I was so bad. I
was so like dark at that time because
that's when I was like super gothic and
all that stuff that I remember coming
home. Actually, I was at the mall when
my friend got the phone call. I was with
my friend and his dad called him on his
cell phone which was like that was back
in the day like barely anybody had cell
phones.
But uh his dad, we were walking around
the mall and then he got off the phone.
He goes, "Oh, I don't know. Dad just
told me like some planes flew through
through some buildings in New York." And
we were just like, "Oh, oh well." you
know, like we were so desensitized by
violence and war and everything you saw
on the news and stuff that it just
didn't even phase us. We're just like,
"Oh, well, things happened or whatever."
>> And then I remember coming home and
opening up the door to my house and my
parents were there. I was living with my
parents, of course. I open the door and
I see the back of my parents' heads like
looking at the screen and uh it showed
people jumping off the building falling
and as I was seeing it I just go wee as
the person was falling and my mom turned
and looked at me with like tears in her
eyes and she was like those are people
Michael and I was just like whatever and
I like walked to my room like that's how
desensitized and dark and I just went
back to my room listened to Marilyn
Manson or whatever and And I think back
on that and I'm just like, man, what a
what a dark place. I can't even believe
I didn't have any kind of value on life
or anything.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, it's really
remarkable how much you are open with
your testimony and I think that is why
you make such an impact because there
are people out there that went through
the same exact thing. I mean our your
our generation and we grew up where you
know Mortal Kombat and all these movies
that were started to you know become
they they weren't even a thing before
our generation the the the graphics the
technology wasn't even there. So just
the desensitization to violence really
started to go into high gear about 20 30
years ago
>> and um it can easily just
make you feel like well whatever people
die all the time like what's the big
deal but it was such a shocking thing
you know 9/11 for me I I had a different
just reaction to it of being more you
know frightened that there was going to
be a war and that people were going to
be drafted and I was paying attention in
the sense of well just well I want to
finish my thought on it being a
demolition building. It's not that I was
immediately a conspiracy theorist. It's
just that's what my brain was seeing. So
that was not me thinking I was smarter
than anyone. It was me just going well
clearly this building's blowing up
before our eyes. How is it just and
there was no way to me for me even to
>> go and question it at the time because
the internet was still growing. And it
wasn't until about 2007 that I came
across a documentary where someone had
put together all the evidence that this
was a planned uh you know event
demolition that we were
>> loose change.
>> It was uh similar. It was called 911
mysteries I believe and it was I I it
wasn't loose change but it was like
that. It was very similar
>> a year.
>> It was like 2007.
>> Wow. Yeah. 2008 was when I saw Loose
Change. So, we were coming to the truth
around the same time.
>> Yeah. And I'm like, whoa, that's crazy.
But then it was at the time still
couldn't talk about it with almost
anyone. Didn't really go looking for
people to talk about it with on the
internet at that time. Just kind of had
in the back of my mind of, you know,
questioning things. And I was really big
into the alien. So, I knew that they
were always uh in my mind hiding aliens
like, oh, maybe they're on the moon or
maybe they've always been here or maybe
we're in contact and they give us
information or maybe they're coming, you
know? So, I always had this kind of
mindset of like, well, what else are we
not being told the truth on and and why?
But you started to realize after 911 how
they use that as an excuse to crack down
on some of more freedoms and to go and
and put ourselves into other positions
for war and to blame people for things
and and make enemies in the world. And
um it wasn't until years later that I
found, hey, a lot of people think 911
was an inside job. And I wasn't alone in
that thought of just going, "Yeah, I
mean, something is up. I don't know what
it was at the time, but something didn't
sit right with me at that age for sure."
But that also was also me going, you
know, by the time we graduated high
school and I'm turning 19 years old, I
was what was out there just wanting to
experience the world. And I think, you
know, you probably want to talk about my
journey through that time period in my
life of um I've been very open that I
come from the LGBTQ community. And I
know that's a lot of people watching
right now are going to be like, "Well,
what the f?" Just want to turn it off.
And that's you're right, dude. I'm not
here to tell you that it's okay and make
excuses for anything. Um, but I can be
honest with what that led me and how it
got me to my my point of having so much
faith today.
>> Yeah, definitely. Continue, Ro. You
>> were captivated. We're on the edge of
our seat. Uh well I mean it's this story
you know
I think at that age first of all when
you're a teenager you're going through
so many changes and obviously you're
growing up and you're kind of realizing
what you like what you don't like and
realizing that I was different again was
like are you kidding me? Because I'd
already grown up Jehovah Witness and um
I had girlfriends in high school but it
was always very just you know surface
level. there wasn't much going on. Um
besides that I loved being around women
and I was like okay I could do this you
know but realizing that I was different
was you know growing up um coming from
me being gay it's like well I'm not gay
I just am comparing myself to these men
going well I wish I had this guy's phys
physique or I wish I you know look like
that or could act like that or whatever
not really realizing that it was more
until down the road in your mind and
you're like oo this is like what people
think is disgusting and people are are
really going to look down on you and
you're going to be judged by your, you
know, the family members that are
religious. And I knew I grew up knowing
what what I thought God had to say about
it and what the Bible says about it. And
I was just like, well, I don't want to
be anything like that. So, I would just
was in denial. And denial is a very
>> powerful thing for for a lot of people.
Obviously, there's all different forms
of denial. And um it wasn't until I was
on my own and just kind of was exploring
going to the club and I got invited to a
gay club and I walked in there just
being like, "Well, I don't know, maybe."
And the music was Britney Spears and it
was bumping and it was like people were
having fun and dancing. I was like, "Oh,
this isn't so crazy after all. This is
like a great party." Um, and so I wasn't
as scared, but I still wasn't ready to,
you know, go all the way with someone.
And I was still nervous and had my
reservations and wanted to protect
myself. Um, so, but the point is that
time period I was exploring just what
gay culture is. And right away I could
tell that things were unfulfilling in
the sense of,
>> you know, you would you start to just
witness the promiscuity. you start to
witness uh how people can be if you're
really looking for love or a
relationship, you're it's going to be
really hard to find basically at any age
in that community unless you get, you
know, someone that you really trust. And
I think that goes for straight people as
well.
>> Um you know, there's a lot of people
that just want to have a solid partner
that they love and trust and want to
build a life with that person and you're
just kind of going off of what you think
you, you know, what you're attracted to.
Um, and so for me, you know, I end up
having a partner for a long time and but
always just feeling still unfulfilled in
in that regard too. Um, feeling like I
you know, it's I think what's what a lot
of people who don't have God in their
lives don't realize what's missing.
>> Yeah. And it took a long time for me to
kind of go through the motions and until
finally get to a point of seeing how
much the world has all lied to us about
many things. if it's not just 9/11, it's
other things with politics or it's money
or it's our history and and you can't
help if you're paying any kind of
attention to the to
>> basically just seeing an agenda unfold
in movies and music, all the um you
know, the blasphemous material, the
satanic worship. I mean, that started to
become more and more clear to me as I
got older into 2018, 2019 and going,
"Well, why are all these pop stars
putting so much symbolism in their music
videos and why is it okay to, you know,
blasphem against Jesus?" And still at
that point hadn't read the Bible for
myself in its entirety or even looked at
the possibility of Jesus could be God.
um hadn't gone there yet because I was
still going well I want to learn about
like I had said I wanted to learn about
space and aliens and then I wanted to go
into the new age and I became a yoga
teacher
>> what
>> and I yeah so I did that in my 20s into
my 30s
>> um just being immersed with what I
thought was like a very loving community
and there are a lot of loving people
just
>> you know that's not the problem the the
problem just like there's loving Jehovah
witnesses uh and this is where I want to
make this message really kind of started
off and and clear there's people in all
walks of life right now that you're not
going to agree with what they're doing
or how they're living their life, but
that doesn't mean that they're not also
included in God's plans.
>> And it's not up to us. My
[clears throat] salvation does not rest
on anyone else's hands. And nobody can.
You can all judge and you can be like,
"Well, this guy doesn't know what he's
talking." But you guys don't know my
individual relationship with God or or
what how I talk to him or what happens
when I disobey my conscience and what
that makes me feel like and how I
reconcile that. I mean, all of that. And
that goes for everybody listening. You
all get your own relationship with with
God, with our creator. And um that's so
important that you don't point the
finger at somebody else and be like,
"Well, you're awful and you're doing all
the things wrong." Because you don't
know if that's what's leading them on a
story arc to come to Christ or to come
to to Jesus or to God and be like, "I
need you because of how unfulfilled."
And you know, when you've shared your
testimony, Mikey, it's like you you were
in a dark place. And that was you had to
kind of
>> go there almost and experience the
darkness. and that depth to appreciate
the light and to notice the difference.
And for me, that's the whole point of
creation, that God started things
perfect and was like, look, I'm starting
you off uh with everything right.
Everything is good and perfect. The only
thing you can't do is this one thing,
which is the fail switch. And if we go
back to Adam and Eve and they're told
not to eat from this tree or they will
die, it's like if that tree didn't exist
at that time, they might never have
believed that they had a choice.
>> That's right.
>> If everything just went on for years and
years perfectly and like, oh, life is
great. If they never had the option to
fail, they might never believe that they
had free will. And so, you know, they
unfortunately for us or or fortunately
how you look at it, they hit the fail
switch early and it sent us on a
trajectory totally like the record
skipped and all of a sudden the Garden
of Eden was shaken because, you know,
they're sitting there enjoying beautiful
trees and flowers and plants and
delicious food that they didn't have to
kill anything ever and they're like,
"Oh, life is great." So all of a sudden
after Eve, you know, ate the apple and
and and the world had shifted, they're
sitting there and they're probably
watching. I always think of this of like
the first lizard starts eyeballing a
fly. It's just like,
>> you know, and it snatched it with its
tongue and it's like boom. And then
they're like, "What the heck was that?"
And then they start to see maybe the
first predator like a lion take down a
gazelle. Could you imagine the horror of
like the first murder that they're
witnessing
>> in nature being like, "This place is
automatically different." And now we are
going to have to reconcile ourselves
back to God, which was always God's
plan. And it was me then coming to Jesus
going, "Oh my gosh, God had this all in
mind from the beginning. He knew and he
still wanted to create." Knowing how
disgusting and dark and violent and
horrible it was going to get. And are we
living in that time of where things are
coming to a head? I mean, that is a huge
part of a Jehovah Witness doctrine is
that they're constantly preaching to
their people that we are in the end. We
are in the end. It's the end times. It's
the last of the end. It's the final
seconds of last minutes. They're just
always putting their people in fear. And
I don't necessarily disagree, but
they've been telling their people that
for over a hundred hundred years, and
they've made many failed predictions
about what the last year would be, which
they call Armageddon.
>> Yeah. And that's why, you know, they're
to me preaching a false gospel and
therefore false prophets and in a
deceived uh works based faith. And so I
want to make sure I kind of wrap up or
we can go back into it. But that all was
pushing me into this time period in my
life of mid30s going, "Okay, I'm not
really getting the answers from space.
There aren't aliens. There's nothing's
coming yet to help us and give us their
wisdom. The new age stuff is only taking
me so far. It can't bring me necessarily
back from the dead. It doesn't offer
everlasting life." And it also isn't
helping me feel u like what is this
shame that I'm feeling? Where is that
coming from?
>> What is shame? Why do I feel that way?
Is that have anything to do with my
lifestyle? And so I started to think
about those things. And then it came to
well,
>> if my mom and my brother and everybody's
going to be pushing this Bible on me and
they want me to study their religion, I
told you, okay, I studied it. Still had
too many questions for them. And then I
go, "Well, it's time for me to read
Jesus's words for myself."
And so I bought a red letter Bible where
every time he speaks, it's in red. So
it's super clear that I'm like, "Okay, I
can start to just go, let's see what he
has to say." And let's take it at face
value that this guy is God walking
around with us. I'm like, "Well, that's
already different than the witnesses
because they're looking at it like God
created something to then therefore go
and sacrifice itself for us." So I'm
like, "Well, where who did Jesus ever
get a say in this?" He was just like,
"Oh, thanks. Thanks a lot." like, "Oh,
okay. Why do I love these people again?"
Uh, you know what I mean? But I'm going
to die for them. No problem. And uh and
I won't ever change. Even though I have
all this power and I share your glory, I
will never deviate from your plan,
Father. However, I'm my own entity. And
I was like, "Okay, maybe." Or how much
cooler would it be if God was like, "All
right, I'm God. I could literally be in
two places at once. I'm going to humble
myself into a human form, and I'm going
to walk around and teach them for
myself." And that way when they go,
"Hey, you don't know what it's like."
He'd be like, "Actually, I know exactly
what it was like. I was there. I did it
perfectly. I did as an example. And I
let you, my creation, murder me for your
salvation." And I was like, "Whoa,
that's just a completely different
>> different way of looking at things." All
of a sudden, it's like, woo, this is a
amazing story that the creator took it
upon himself. And he kind of knew that
if he was going to be walking around on
the earth that the Pharisees and the
skeptics would be like, well, if you're
God, then who's up in heaven? And he's
like, well, God is able to be in
multiple places at one time. I'm to play
the role of father, the son, and spirit.
And I will be in three places. And uh I
will walk with my creation from
basically the days of Adam and Eve as
the Lord God walked around in the garden
to different times throughout the Old
Testament. and I I will come and I will
reveal myself cuz God I think is a great
storyteller and I think that the story
of humanity
>> told man
>> for sure and so if he's like I'm going
to tell a story I'm going to tell it
right I'm going to make sure that nobody
looks back and be like well I would have
done this cuz he's like no no no it's
going to be gnarly and you're going to
appreciate what I have in store for you
as you get to know me and I'm going to
help you trust me and that's was the
most interesting part of what my journey
did for me was opening up that line of
communication with with God going, "Hey,
I'm gonna start talking to it. I'm going
to start reading its word. I'm going to
start meditating on the word." Meaning,
you know, contemplating what is the
message. And some days were a few
scriptures to whole books of the Bible
because I just couldn't get enough. And
I'm still studying. And I I also want to
be make sure people understand like I'm
in the middle of my journey. It's taken
me very far in a short amount of time uh
as far as my belief and my faith. And I
realized that coming from a works-based
religion that's deceived preaching
preaching a false gospel um and the
mental turmoil that they're in that they
don't even realize is the opposite of
freedom. And when you have the faith in
the true creator and you understand the
message of the Bible because you've seen
enough lies and you're fed up with
enough deception and you come from a
life of so much
there's just debauchery right and um
things that going well I don't really
necessarily want to partake and res that
doesn't resonate with me in my
conscience to just have a promiscuous
lifestyle. Um, you kind of have to go
through those things to start to listen
to your heart, your conscience, I should
say, um, about, well, I want to feel
good. I want to feel like I'm on the
right path. And for me, that was the
word of God. So,
>> Amen, brother. That's amazing.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I can identify with so
much of what you're saying and and you
you really just explained it so well
because,
you know, I've dealt with a lot of
atheists and stuff and I had my own
thoughts. I was never an atheist because
I was intrigued with the paranormal and
supernatural, but I was definitely an
agnostic and thought that the church
didn't have the answers. It must be
somewhere else. And um I went more down
the road of the occult. I was never
really into the new age stuff, but uh
the question of why, if God is all
loving and all powerful, why is there
suffering in the world? Why did he even
put that tree in the garden? All these
things. And I remember the first time I
found this little book on the in the
hospital where I was um doing valet, and
it was this little pocket-size book and
the first chapter said, "Why is there
suffering?" And I was like, "Whoa,
that's a good question."
And um I never heard it explained so
well as I had in that book, but it was
talking about how
it's like a commentary and it was
everybody was in, you know, all the
angels were in heaven. Everything was
perfect. They knew they knew nothing
other than perfection.
And Lucifer got this pride in his spirit
like he was saw his beauty. I mean this
is written in Ezekiel or Isaiah. I
always get this too confused, but it
talks about how every precious stone was
his covering and he was perfect in all
his ways until iniquity was found in him
by his brightness of his beauty and all
this stuff. And so he wanted to be like
God. He knew that Jesus
had well he knew that Jesus was higher
than him and he wanted that power. He's
for some reason something came over him
that made him envious, made him prideful
and made him feel like I should have as
much power as he does. And nobody had
ever experienced anything sinful. So
when this thought came into his mind, it
like was like a discordant note in a
song, a perfect orchestra harmony.
That's another thing that's amazing
about, you know, if you don't believe in
God or something, why is art so
beautiful? Why do how can you hear a
song for the first time and if that note
is played wrong, you notice you notice
that that note is played wrong. How?
You've never heard the song before?
Because there's an order. There's a law
to everything that doesn't happen with
an explosion in outer space. All right?
And why do you cry there? You know, if
if we're evolved amiebas
and and our whole brain is based on
fight or flight, survival and
reproduction, then why do we cry? Why do
we have, you know, we see something and
we have emotion? Tears make no sense in
a fight orflight or, you know, kill or
be killed situation. And so when Lucifer
got this feeling, this emotion, it was
like this discordant note in heaven that
just made a dreadful feeling come upon
everyone. And they're like, "What is
going on? Like why is he acting so
different? What is this?" And he was so
close to God. Lucifer was like the
highest angel
that he was able to convince a third of
the angels that God is not who you think
he is. You know, imagine
um if you or I said, "Oh, the
president's really like this." Well, who
are we? We don't do you know him or
whatever. But imagine if the vice
president comes out and goes on national
television and says, "I've seen him
behind closed doors. These are what he's
doing." Lucifer had that type of
uh reputation, you know, authority that
he could say, "I'm so close to him. This
is who he is behind closed doors. He's
hiding something from you." He is trying
to keep all of us from being elevated to
his level and he's trying to keep us
from evolving. And that's where the new
age movement comes from. Right from the
Garden of Eden, God put that tree in the
garden because if there if there is no
option to rebel, then you really don't
have free choice. If if I'm on a Well,
there's so many different analogies, you
know, if you're on a deserted island and
you stumble upon the only other
companion on the island and they tell
you they love you. Well, how how can you
know? There's nobody else to choose. Or
if you put a gun to somebody's head and
say, "Tell me you love me." And they say
the words, are you really experiencing
love? No. Because they're saying the
words out of fear for their own life. So
they can say the words, but how do they
how can you ever ever prove that they
love you? And so God gave Adam and Eve
this perfect world and said, "You can
have everything, just not this tree. If
you eat of this tree, it'll cause chaos.
You'll die and all these things. Do you
trust me? Do you believe what I'm
saying?" And when Lucifer again came
into the garden, the same one that was
able to deceive a third of the angels,
trillions of angels, he he deceived a
third of them. He came in that garden as
this beautiful reptilian creature,
saying, "If you eat this fruit, your
eyes will be open. You will become like
God." God isn't God doesn't want you to
have knowledge. This is the tree of
knowledge, and he's telling you not to
eat it. Why? Because he doesn't want you
to overthrow him. He doesn't want you to
become to the level that he is. And
that's the same thing that we see in our
world today. You you look at these
people who have had these alien
abduction experiences and stuff which
are really just um it's like an out-of-
body experience. It's a it's a delusion
that Satan can get put on people if they
are dabbling in the occult and stuff
like that. And you have reptilian
creatures saying you can never die.
You'll become like God. Like the story
is always the same. When these people
get abducted, it's always they travel
from millions of light years away to
tell you Jesus isn't who you think he is
and you are God within and you can never
die and you can evolve and all these
things and it it it goes right back to
the garden.
>> Mhm. [snorts] Well, that's part of I
credit my u research into the paranormal
of seeing the
the um comparisons and and the
coincidences that it are these aliens
actually just demons, you know? So, if I
hadn't been studying the aliens stuff
for so long and paying attention and
really trying to wrap my head around,
okay, who made the pyramids and the
ancient civilizations and were they made
from, you know, other beings to the
Bible being like, yeah, they were made,
you know, like there were other beings
here at least, I should say, that maybe
influenced man or helped make these
amazing structures that God wiped out in
a flood versus, you know, these remnants
of aliens technology. It's like what if
it was just more of the ethereal, the
spiritual realm, meaning the physical,
and could these stories then be taken at
face value as truth? And I started to
look at it through the lens of, yeah,
what if this is true that the Bible,
this dusty old book, all of a sudden it
should be glowing bright gold everywhere
because it's got so much knowledge and
wisdom of of the facts of our earth. And
seeing how far the mainstream is willing
to go to twist our history to try to
keep our mind out in the stars and these
other beings versus God could be right
above us in a physical realm. Um,
meeting, you know, right above the earth
and that there was a time where things
fell from heaven and came to the earth
and influenced mankind and deceived us.
And what a gnarly uh story if that were
to be true. And today I'm like, yeah,
this makes sense, you know? So, it kind
of ties back into
how did I come to terms with this book
and and why? I mean, how how much longer
could I be if we all have a conscience
and you know, when you're doing right
from wrong, I had to figure out, well,
where does that come from?
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> you know, why do I feel all these things
of, you know, not just is there
suffering in the world, but why do I
know the difference between when I do
something right or wrong? I mean, basic
things of, you know, if you tell a lie
or if you're, you know, get so upset
with someone or if you're being selfish
or if these sexual or desires of the
flesh and you're using people to satisfy
these desires versus going for love and
and doing those things. I mean, that's
part of the culture of like what whether
you're gay or straight, hookup culture
has become a thing, you know, the past
at least, you know, couple generations
of you're lucky if you find someone for
love and that you trust them entirely
and explicitly enough to devote yourself
to them forever. And and that's the only
time that God blesses a desire of the
flesh is through the sanctity of of
virgin marriage, right? And so if you're
not practicing about it, it doesn't
matter if you're gay or straight. You're
you're on the same path to destruction
without a savior.
>> And um so, you know, at this point in my
journey, it's like I didn't really
understand the sanctification process. I
didn't understand that God is polishing
people right now. I didn't understand
that there's people that are struggling
with sin and that the sin lives in our
skin and that it's there's no excuse for
it, but there is a solution. And over
time through prayer and trust in God,
you it can you can start to make better
choices, you know, and that doesn't mean
you're always going to make the right
choice, but it means when you fail, you
know who to talk to rather than without
God, you're making an excuse for it.
>> And you might even realize you're doing
that of like, well, I just need to do
this. So, if you're a straight guy and
you're just sleeping around with women
every night and you don't care about
those women that you're not, you don't
want to know their feelings, you don't
want to commit to them, but you're
getting what you want. That's that's
part of being selfish, right? And it's
not just desires of the flesh. And if
you have a conscience, it's going to
start being like, look, you're you're
hurting these people. Why are you
continuing to do that? And that's where
God's trying to reach people like that.
Like, hey, you you don't have to go
about it this way. You're hurting
yourself and others. And I think what I
started to lean into because I had so
many family members that were condemning
me and I was like, well, where's the
mercy of this loving God?
>> And I started to read about how his
mercy is overpower sin and that he knows
better than any of us of what the the
arsenal of
temptation and distraction um that the
evil has has its grip on this world. I
mean, you could turn out a burger
commercial and and be lusting after the
person in the video. I mean, look at
remember those all this sex over
sexualization of things and you you know
the Bible's like thou shalt not covet
yet everything is about well who's doing
what who has what this materialistic
worldview and you know it starts to chip
away at your soul your your just your
happiness if you are somebody who's
coveting after other things being like I
wish I had that or I wish I was doing
this instead of what I'm doing if you
don't have God in your life you might
get stuck thinking like well this is it
I just was dealt a odd hand.
>> My future doesn't mean anything. My my
existence doesn't mean anything. And
there's no hope for me because the world
we live in says everything's random. And
then and if if you die, that's it. And
therefore, you better have fear of
missing out. Otherwise, you know, you
had a bad life. And if that were to be
true, then I could see why people try to
scratch and claw their way for all sorts
of things. money, power, fame,
attention, beauty, whatever versus no,
you were made with intention. Your life,
this life is not the forever life. And
there is much more promised and this is
more of you developing who God wants to
hang out with. I mean, amen.
>> That's what right now is about. Like,
who does God want to hang out with in
the long run? You know, he wants people
who love him for him, people who trust
him for him. And he's very patient. I
mean, it can take a whole lifetime to
get to that point and that's okay for
the person who's on their deathbed and
is like, I get it now versus someone who
might be lucky and gets it as a kid. So,
God is kind of going
>> Yeah. Exactly. And so, you know, I I've
learned not to judge anyone and um not
that I'm perfect. Like I said, guys, I'm
still learning. I'm still having to talk
to God on my walk. And even if you took
away, oh, I believe that I I identified
as a gay person,
>> it you're you're forgetting the part of
becoming a new creation when you have
faith and you believe and you give
yourself to Christ. And you know,
getting baptized for me was a way of,
you know, showing my faith. But did that
mean I all of a sudden was perfect? It's
like, no. But I also knew I made it a
lot easier to make better choices and
immediately have, you know, what we call
repentance, which is just expressing
you. Like people ask me like, "What is
repentance? What is sin?" And I'm like,
"Well, anytime you've made a decision
that you regret, I think that pretty
much falls into the line of sin." And
so, have you ever done that? And they're
like, "Yeah." And I'm like, "Well,
you're talking to someone about it." And
he's going, "You're not so delusional
that you're going to try to ignore it.
You're actually communicating with me.
And there will be days where it's easy
and there will be days where you're
under, you know, such stress about
things and you might fail. But does that
mean you're condemned? No. It means that
you're going to get back up and you're
going to talk to God about it and let
him carry you along and him show you why
you need him. And then maybe those
decisions that were bad that you're
making, maybe they get easier. Maybe you
stop making those same mistakes because
you stop, you realize you're just lying
to God. If you're like, "Oh, God, I
won't do it again." and then you do it
again and they're like, "Oh god, I'm so
sorry." And then you do it again. And
he's like, he's not up there going
necessarily keeping tabs of how many
times you say sorry. He's keeping tabs
if you actually mean it or not.
>> Right.
>> And so if you mean it or not, you know,
then if you if you really are trying to
get better, he knows that the sin which
lives in our skin, which is the most
terrible thing in all of existence, how
hard it is, knowing the arsenal, like I
said, the bombardment of all the
distractions and the things to push us
in the wrong ways. He's just going, you
know, use him as windshield wipers on
your site so you have something to focus
on so you can keep talking to him about
what you're wanting to get better at.
And I just want to encourage people like
no matter what you come from, that's
your aim. And for me, people are always
going to wonder like what about your
sexuality? I'm like, dude, number one
goal is to love God first.
>> Amen.
>> And whatever that means for me. So, I
can just tell you that's my journey. I'm
in the middle of it. And I'm learning
how to love God first over everybody
else and anyone else and anything else.
And it's I'm it's it's been amazing.
It's changed me. It's made me feel so
much better. It's given me so much more
hope and peace. But also, there's always
work to be done. And desires of the
flesh are just one thing. We all have
something to work on. And if you try to
act like you don't have it in you, if
you if you try to say you don't have sin
in you, then you don't have the truth.
That's straight from the word of God.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you know, just
>> the DJ up in here, bro.
>> Well, like look, we want to have you
want to have hope out there. And there's
people that they feel so much shame,
though. They're like, well, why would
God even care about me? And I'm like,
that's the perfect person to reach out
to the Lord
>> and to and just be like, dude, God, I'm
sorry. And he's going to be like, I get
it. This is an uphill battle that I'm
going to help you along. And um I'm just
so grateful to God for all the
forgiveness he's shown me and for all
the patience and just the times where
I've really felt down on myself or made
mistakes. And
>> I I am I do feel that sense of just God,
I'm sorry. Help me. And it's it's a work
in progress and I'm getting better. But
I I feel good about knowing that it's
it's the path, you know, it's the path
towards truth. It's the path towards
something that we can't imagine how
great it is. And and I don't want to be
cheesy, and I know anyone talking about
this can come off like, well, you know,
if you try to act like all of a sudden
you're perfect, that's not my message.
It's you're still going to struggle and
you still could fail, but you're
supposed to get back up
>> and don't let anyone else's, you know,
opinion of things lose your relationship
with God directly. And um it's a nice
reminder for myself and I hope it helps
someone out there.
>> Man, I know it. I know it has. I see
some great comments coming in here.
People are touched by your story. I know
I am. I know that this has
>> been a nice little change of pace for
our channel when we're often saying, you
know, this thing is happening, this evil
thing is going on and and you're here
bringing this light of hope to people
and you know, you're you're spitting so
much scripture out there. you know, Jes
or uh Paul was saying that thing that I
don't want to do, I do. And that thing,
you know, he he was talking about the
struggle, how I don't want to do it, but
I do it anyway. And and the Bible says
that a righteous man falls seven times
and gets back up. It the thing that's
the sin is to sin and stay down. You
know, that's when you're when Satan
wins, when he gets defeat over you,
we're all going to be tempted and at
times we will fall. We're we're not
perfect, but when we fall, we have to
understand that we need Christ and we
ask for repent. We ask for forgiveness.
We repent. We turn from that sin. We get
back up and we we pick up our cross and
we let Jesus hold our hand and give us
the victory and it might happen again,
you know. But that's why it says a
righteous man gets up seven times. You
don't stay down and say, "Well, I'm
defeated."
Um, you know, we think of these apostles
as these stained glass perfect people,
and yet I love how honest the Bible is.
Moses killed a guy. Moses didn't even
get to make it into the promised land.
He was chosen by God, was the only one
allowed on that mountain. And yet, he
didn't even make it into the promised
land. was not heaven, but he didn't make
it to the promised land because he got
angry at that rock when it didn't when
he was supposed to well, he got angry at
the people.
>> And um you know, Peter denied Christ
three times in in Christ's most
vulnerable moment, like the last hours
of his life, and he says, "I don't even
know him." You know, and cussed and
said, "I don't know him." And when Jesus
came back, he said, "Do you love me? Do
you love me? Do you love me? You know,
he always forgave. He still forgives. He
forgave a thief on the cross who did
rightfully deserve to be on that cross
and in his dying moment said, I
recognize you are the son of God. And uh
I'm I want to be with you, you know,
remember me. And Jesus said, you will be
with me in paradise.
>> And yeah, man, it's just I love hearing
your story. I love seeing your journey.
You have been uh an awesome ray of light
here and a a beacon of hope and I know
that your story is gonna reach a lot of
people. Man, I really appreciate you
coming on and sharing it.
>> For sure. Well, thank you for giving me
the opportunity and and people out
there, you know, it's if we didn't have
this, come on, what do we have then if
we don't have hope? And I had to lean
into the mercy of God because I needed
it. And I know that that goes for
everyone. and whether someone you know
I'm not making excuses for any lifestyle
if it's not you know blessed by God. So,
but the point is I also want to help
people who feel excluded from maybe
God's love or think that, well, this
book just has me condemned when they
don't realize that that's what you were
once you believe you're changed
>> and you still will struggle and you
still will fail and get back up, but you
you have the hand to reach out for
that's always there for you. and that
I've experienced and God, you know,
gives me nice um reassurance in in ways
that are just incredible and his word
lifts me up and knowing um the mercy of
our God, our creator is just so much
can't put a limit on it. I think that's
so beautiful and we're really just I
know that he has a plan and for the
people seeking truth again that's why
looking into all truth matters
>> and really have dropping your
It will set you free. It'll give you
peace that surpasses all understanding.
And just having that and if if Jesus is
the way, the truth, and the life, then
it all leads to him. And as a witness,
I'm not ready to look as an ex-witness,
I'm not ready to look him in the face
and say, "You're not God." Like like
they're fully prepared to do
>> because that's uh that's not that I
don't have hope for them. Of course, I
do. I think that there as time goes on,
I would imagine that God is going to
start waking up more people. And if
you're in that religion and you're
feeling trapped or you're feeling like
you're never good enough or you don't
know where your salvation is at or
you're, you know, you're not really
fully seeing the bigger picture of of
what I'm trying to say here, it's like
ask yourself, I mean, do how are you
saved? Do you know, do you have that
feeling? I mean, why do you feel scared
to question your your own religion? and
and to start watching some of these XJW
testimonies and researching, you know,
where the Watchtower made false
predictions because any false prediction
is therefore a false prophet if it's
it's not from God if it doesn't come
true. And
>> you know, they've managed to
um grip a lot of generations which is
how that organization is holding
together people born into it that are
afraid to lose their friends and family.
And the scriptures even warns of this
end times deception of people falling
for false Christ. So doing everything in
your power to go and study it and and
look into things for yourself is is I
think so important. But I also have hope
that God his plan really is unfolding.
And I don't worry too much that anything
will ever be unfair or someone didn't
have 100% fair chance or what God wasn't
trying to reach somebody. It's like, no,
he he's doing things right and it'll not
hindsight will be 2020. And for the
people that are believers, just knowing
that that's also part of God's plan from
the beginning and we're we don't we're
not going to understand how everything
works here, why things happen until
later on in life. And if you're someone
watching that like, well, I don't trust
this book even. It's like, okay, well,
start to look into its wisdom. start to,
you know, where it makes a historical
claim, see if it was accurate. Where it
makes a scientific claim, see if it was
accurate. If it's making a claim about
the earth, start to at least tally up
all the wisdom that this book has and
then continue on from there. But getting
to the truther side, I hate to even say
we have the truth because I think that's
an ever unfolding thing that's leading
being more and more revealed like the
light growing brighter and the witnesses
twist that also. And that's how they
manipulate their members through a
governing body rather than going
straight back to the word. So everything
should always point you back to the word
which therefore is Jesus which therefore
is God. And it's like the voice of God
coming forward um in our realm to give
us a light to to to navigate
>> the terrible atrocities of of of
existence. You know, we all have seen
the suffering. We know that when you're
blessed, you can feel guilty about it
sometimes because there's people out
there really going through hardship. And
just having that faith that God is
paying attention to the truth in all
matters and is going to reconcile things
um gives me so much hope and peace to
get on the internet and start talking
about literally the world's craziest
things. Um and being so open, you know.
So,
>> Amen.
>> Thank you for
>> I did want to address this. I mean, if
if you guys are a part of JW or know
somebody, I mean, this is a huge red
flag to me. This is Jehovah's Witness
Headquarters aerial view. I mean,
there's no denying what that is. I mean,
it's not just like, oh, it's in the
shape of a triangle. I mean, that is an
allseeing eye all the way. And you
combine that with their new world order
translation or I mean new world
translation
>> and you know saying that you know
changing the scriptures to say that he
was a god you know um I have some verses
here I don't know if this is you know
this isn't all of them these are just
some that I looked up um is the does the
Bible ever say that Jesus is worshiped
and it says here in Hebrew Hebrews 1:6
it says, "And again when he brings the
firstborn into the world, he says, "Let
all God's angels worship him." John
20:28, this was doubting Thomas, you
know, when he said, "I won't believe
it's you unless I can feel the holes,
the wounds in your side and in your
hands." And after he felt it, it said
Thomas answered him, "My Lord and my
God." He's calling Jesus his God. Um, it
might have even said he he began to
worship him. Uh, Matthew 28, "And
behold, Jesus met them and said
greetings, and they came up and took
hold of his feet and worshiped him."
Now, this isn't people being blasphemous
and and defying the first commandment.
Jesus never said, "Whoa, get up. Don't
do that to me." That did happen in
Revelation. In Revelation when John was
in vision, he heard a voice behind him
uh an angel and it says, "I fell down to
worship at the feet of the angel who
showed me who showed them to me. But he
said to me, you must not do that. I am a
fellow servant with you and your
brothers, the prophets, and with those
who keep the words of this book. Worship
God." He said, "Don't do that to me."
The angel said, "Don't do that." But
Jesus never did that. Um
>> Mhm.
>> you know from from his birth he was
worshiped literally at the manger. It
says that um the people that were
following the star they said this is the
son of God. They began to worship him.
Angels
in in Revelation you see uh elders
casting their feet at his or casting
their crowns at his feet. you see angels
and men worshiping Jesus and um you know
I think this is what you're saying that
the Jehovah's Witness are are
demoting Christ to not being God not
being divine and saying that you cannot
worship Jesus to worship him is actually
blasphemous
but we're we're told to worship him
>> you absolutely and those are all great
scriptures to pull out in their New
World Translation, the New World Order
translation, it has changed key words.
Like for example, where it says worship
in a King James, it'll say obesence.
That they're saying, "Oh, we pay
obedience to him." But really, what I
found the most just boiled down version
of what I've come to understand or
believe at this point, um, is that when
you demote Jesus and you don't have that
relationship, I mean, the will of the
father is to believe in the son. And the
son says, "If you love me, you love the
father." Amen.
>> And to divide God from the father, it's
like Jesus over and over is like we are
one. Where does he ever say we are two?
>> Where does he ever say I am a separate
thing? Where does he ever say that the
father created me? I mean, nobody has
been able to show me that. They've taken
things out of context and say that he's
firstborn and that he's a divine entity,
this thing, but he's not the true
creator. It's like look, if he's not the
creator, then
why is he accredited with creating all
things? You know what I mean? Like, oh,
someone the witnesses will be like,
>> yeah, the witnesses will say, oh, you
know, the father told him to do it. So,
I'm like, I use the analogy, okay, well,
if you commission an artist to paint a
painting for you, is the person who
commissioned it the creator?
>> No.
>> They're the person who paints the
painting is the artist. They're the
creator of that. And so, you know, if
it's really important to try to see if
they have the same will, then that's
like I look at it like Jesus is the
avatar for God. He's the physical form,
the visible of the invisible. If God is
the spirit who's invisible, then Jesus
is the image that has been put forth.
It's as if when we talk, if if our voice
just became a visible thing, it's how he
relates to us. It was his humble down
version of God being in the human form.
Something that we could, you know,
really come to love and to try to
understand because again, it's all the
purpose is for us to learn how to love
and trust God and it's through the son.
That's the will of the father. And
eventually, we don't know what God has
in store. I mean, if we're made in the
image and likeness of God and God and
Jesus is the image and likeness, then
Jesus is God. And so therefore, the
first step is for us to start to trust
it and and to read his word and to love
him for what he had to say because we
know that it feels intuitively true and
that it can't be disproven. So these are
all things that will help give you
faith. And eventually, you know, the
Bible goes way into the future saying
how things are going to be made new and
that we don't even know, we can't even
imagine what God has in store for his
creation. And so
>> to [clears throat] me that means
limiting the whole point of why God's
taking all this time to help develop his
creation. He's like one day you guys are
going to be something you don't even
realize yet with with me. And you know
we we can't limit what that means. It
just means thinking it worrying about
the day like Jesus taught. And if you
have a great day then you give your
gratitude to God. If you have a day
where you're weak, you talk to him on
that day and then you, you know, you
allow it to reset each day and um you'll
start to feel and and get better in my
opinion. And um it's really helped me
and it revealed a lot. I mean, I would
have never believed or come to even
consider that the earth is not where
we've been told or that it's at the
center of creation if I didn't have this
uh biblical worldview, which I'd been
studying the scriptures first. And God
was kind of like, "All right, well, why
don't you go look into evolution?" And
so I started to study it
>> and I realized, well, are things not
changing then over time? And the Bible
says it was made everything according to
its kind. And I was like, okay. And
well, what other proof of evolution is
there? So I started to talk to I have a
client who is a professor at a college
who his specializes in anthropology. And
I asked him a question that I had seen
asked around online going, "What is the
single best piece of observable evidence
to prove evolution?" And he couldn't
give me an observable piece. And what I
found was the excuses. He's like, "Well,
it takes a long time." And I'm like,
"Okay, no problem." Didn't want to
pressure him. But I started to realize
that in order for Darwin's theory of
evolution to be true, he even admitted
in his own book um on natural selection
that he's missing the bones that
mutations don't necessarily mean that
it's going to be something better than
what it already was and that for all the
time that it took for things to be as
diverse on the earth that we see, so all
the amount of different animals,
insects, reptiles, birds, you know,
mammals, etc. the v the variety that's
here that would for those things to all
have mutated into what they are and how
balanced they are in their ecosystems
>> that would take billions of years longer
than the age of the earth I mean the
mathematical equations are beyond for
the diversity that's here so I started
to realize this is not survival of the
fittest earth is literally thriving and
then the word of God is like look at the
birds they don't even have to plant
seeds and yet your heavenly father takes
care of them
>> all each and every single kind of bird
and mammal and reptile. They all made it
this far. Don't you think you're more
important than the birds? It's like,
whoa, it started to become just so
powerful. And it doesn't matter what my
background is. I would never ignore
that. It doesn't matter what community I
came from. It doesn't matter any of
that. As a human being, seeing the
deception, knowing the suffering,
feeling that there's evil presence,
seeing the agendas play out in movies
and music, and then understanding that
there there might not be anything else
out there. We can't leave the earth. The
Bible all has the answer. I was like,
"How could I ignore this book?" And why
why would I ignore this book? And um you
know, that's where I'm at today. I'm
like, I just want to know more. I'm
going to keep studying. I'm going to
keep going.
>> Amen. Bro, you're you're killing it,
man. That was a great interview, great
testimony, great sermon. You've been
sharing some awesome Bible scriptures.
And I want to just remind people that if
they want to see you, they can find you
on Mark Sergeant's YouTube channel on
Strange World. I'm underneath the live
tab right here because you guys go live
every Tuesday at what time?
>> 7 7 PM Pacific. And yeah, hop in there.
You guys come check out the channel.
It's got all sorts of interviews of flat
earth testimonies, people, you know,
doing amazing things in the community.
Um, we do call-in shows. So, if you're
somebody who wants to call in, ask a
question or just get things off your
chest, please look for a call-in show.
And then we also do um different
roundts. We just did one on biblical
cosmology. We're going to do another one
about wild conspiracies coming up here
in December. Looks like we're going to
have Mikey there for that one, which
will be great. And um Mikey will be on
um next week for his own interview on
Strange World with Aubrey. And I'm so
looking forward to that as well. And
it's just kind of like the in-house flat
earth family show.
>> We're not really trying to market or
even that's not the right word, but
we're not really trying to get new
people to look into flat earth there
necessarily unless you go the clues
route. We're more of like the people who
have kind of questioning everything and
you could be on the biblical route or
you're like look it's a simulation or I
don't know. Point is come hang out with
us. We're talk about everything. So
>> the the questioning everything talk
show. I love it man.
>> Yeah. Well, bro, thank you so much for
coming on, man. It's been a blessing.
I'm I'm so I'm so blessed to get to hear
more of your story. I only got to hear
parts of it when we were hanging out and
so there was a lot of cool things that
were brought out and it's been a it's
been a very encouraging talk and I'm I
know that people were blessed and so I
just want to say thank you
>> and uh stick around, man, as I sign off
and I'll get to talk to you afterwards.
Well, and thank you and thanks for
everybody for listening.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, thanks again for everybody. Thanks.
And uh please feel free to reach out to
me. You can find me at
djcuriousworldgmail.com
or again you can u find us on Mark's
channel. But also if you're out there
and you're just struggling with things
and you're still, you know, please just
I offer I I want to make sure you know
you can always talk to God about
whatever you're going through. He's
always ready to listen. And it's it's an
uphill battle, but it's so much easier
with help and a guidance and and just
thank you for being kind enough to let
me share my story. It's it's a blessing
and I hope it helps people out there and
it's still helping me. So, thank you.
>> Amen. Awesome, man. Well, I hope you
guys enjoyed the show. If you did,
please click a thumbs up. It really
helps get this video out into the
algorithm. And we can't do this without
you guys. We've been doing this for
about a year and a half now, and God has
been providing through generous donors
like you. If you would like to support
this channel, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got Cash App, Vinmo,
Zel, PayPal. We even have Patreon on
there. And we got some cool t-shirts. If
you guys would like to get a t-shirt, we
get about $5 uh on every sale from
those. And this shirt goes perfect with
DJ's testimony. God's not done with you
yet. Those are available on our website.
You know, God's working on all of us.
None of us have arrived. It's all a
walk, a growth, picking up our cross
daily, running this race, and those who
finish the race will get a crown of
life. And I pray that if you've never
made that decision to make Jesus Christ
the Lord and Savior of your life, that
you will do it today. Because if you
ever watch this channel, you'll see the
signs of the times are here. Like, Jesus
is coming soon. New world order is
coming soon. What is what is there to
wait for? There's nothing that this
world has to offer. I've already had a
taste of it all and I can tell you like
Solomon, vanity, vanity, it's all
vanity. As for me in my house, we will
serve the Lord. Choose ye this day whom
you will choose and you will never,
ever, ever regret it. It's the best
decision you can ever make. I love you
guys. God bless you and we'll see you
next time on Candid Truth.